Do you think you could
be friends with a robot?
Would you maybe
even die for one?
Anthony here, for D News.
And we love to
anthropomorphic stuff.
That's where we
assign human qualities
to animals or objects.
You know like, that electrical
socket looks hungry,
or that lamp is sad.
Probably because that electrical
socket is eating its tail.
Researchers think it
helps us feel connected
to things, gives us
a feeling of control.
We might not understand
why our car is broken down,
but it makes us feel
less overwhelmed to say,
oh, it's just mad at me.
This becomes particularly
interesting with something
like a robot, which is
built to actually behave
like it does have
a mind of its own.
Recently a lot of studies
and pilot programs
have shown that the elderly
and disabled, especially people
with dementia can benefit from
the social interaction that
comes with having a
simple robot in the house.
It can keep them
more engaged and make
them feel less isolated.
But there's a downside to that
sort of anthropomorphizing.
A recent university
of Washington study
suggests that forming
emotional bond to a robot
might affect a soldiers
outcome in the field.
See, robots are used for a
lot of reasons in battle.
Everything from weapon
diffusion to search and rescue,
even combat.
There a tool design to keep
humans out of harm's way.
But after a while,
soldiers begin
to look at them as friends.
And the concern is that might
compromise their decision
making.
23 soldiers that work
regularly with robots
were interviewed
by the researchers.
And they all said that
they named their robots,
they gave their
robots a gender, they
admitted to having
feelings of sadness
or anger when the
robot got damaged.
They would say things
like, oh poor little guy.
And in some cases, the soldiers
admitted to a feeling of loss
when the robot was
destroyed and even
had mock funerals for them.
They're considered team members.
But while they admitted to
thinking of their robots
as little buddies, every
soldier interviewed
said that they did not believe
that that outlook compromised
their decision making
in the field at all.
Which is probably true.
But it would require much
more long term observation
of their behavior in the
field to actually prove it.
Researchers are more
concerned about what
happens when the current simple
Rover Wally looking robots
are replaced by humanoid or
animal like ones like Boston
Dynamics big dog.
The more a robot seems
like a living thing,
the more we get attached to it.
And the more we begin to give
it credit for more intelligence
or ability than it actually has.
And that doesn't just
mean physical appearance,
that means movement or
other behavior as well.
So how lifelike
would a robot have
to be before a soldier really
does look at it like a pet?
Or even like another soldier?
And could it lead them to
make emotionally inappropriate
decisions to keep that
robot out of harm's way?
I worry about my
neighbors in animal
crossing like they
are real people.
So I can absolutely
see myself getting way
to attached to a robot.
What about you?
Do you think that
we will eventually
see robots as friends?
Or will we always be able
to think of them as tools?
Let us know down below and
subscribe for more D News.